women will spend years
changing her man and then wonder what
the hell happened to the guy that she
fell in love with
and they inadvertently do this stuff
this is this is just part of female
nature
um it can take it can take quite a few
years
and a lot of the times you don't notice
it happening if i'm being honest
uh it just it just happens through small
concessions here like
it starts with basic stuff like hey rich
put your white socks in the white hamper
and your dark socks and the
dark hamper and don't brush your teeth
over there because you're going to get
toothpaste on the carpet and like you
know small things like this here and
there whereas
you know in the past previously you just
kind of threw your laundry wherever you
felt like it
and you'd walk all over the house
without any clothes on brushing your
teeth wherever the hell you want it
because
you're a man and your entire house is
your castle then all of a sudden you
know you start to get all these
restrictions and limitations and
boundaries put around
your life and as you comply with each
one of them you start going through the
process of beta tization
through a thousand concessions it turns
men from a pet that she loves and
admires into a plow horse
that she sees nothing more than a
utility a utility that she is going to
emotionally abuse
and doesn't want to bang
enthusiastically anymore
if you aren't aware and you don't
control the frame of the relationship
then chances are this is going to happen
to you it will make you weak soft poor
undesirable to your woman this process
of betatization
by a thousand concessions is a genuine
threat especially if you cohabitate
and get into a relationship and if you
have kids
guys that lose access to their kids i
can't tell you how many
women i met after i got divorced with
children in tow that were all divorced
of course
that left their husbands because 8 out
of 10 times is women leaving the men
and the lack of contact the father has
with his own children
the amount of money he flows for the
amount of bitching that you got to
listen to
about that all because she deemed the
guy as a beta
and i've seen some of these guys right
like you see them like you know the
younger
uh photos where they have like the uh
you know the barbed wire like around
their biceps sort of thing like they
were dudes at one point many of these
guys
but a lot of men go through this process
in a marriage
and if you're not managing the frame and
this is where
frame really matters quite uh quite a
bit a lot of people go oh it's frame
rich you know
what is this whole frame thing in every
relationship
one person enters the other's frame okay
the man enters her frame
or she enters his frame happens all the
time
sometimes it's back and forth right but
at the end of the day if she's not
operating in your frame
and you're operating in her frame you
will go through beta tization through a
thousand concessions
this is where the risks start to you
know become problematic
if you get divorced you lose custody of
your kids you might only see them every
other weekend and like a wednesday night
for dinner
my lawyer calls that the screw over
daddy deal
these things will happen to beta men
more often alpha men women don't divorce
alpha guys they don't they don't run off
and start
banging somebody else or hanging out
with kevin from
sales or steve from accounting by the
way steve from accounting edited my book
did you know that
if you follow me on instagram you'd know
that by now but
that's how it goes they just don't run
off on guys that they're
uh happy with guys that they look at and
their
hypergamous hindbrain is like
everything's fine i dig this guy's vibe
why would i want to do anything with
kevin from sales they just don't
um anyway so often you'll get introduced
to
her family you know around the holidays
we got thanksgiving coming up i know
some places you guys will be able to get
together and other places you just won't
because of the scam endemic but it is
what it is but you know you'll be
introduced to family and
you know oh this is rich you know the
entrepreneur
they'll tell the big story and everybody
gathers around and they're like oh he's
a swell guy
and he's so classy and all that sort of
stuff and they all fondly look
upon him but over time and you'll see
this five years
seven years ten years down the road the
woman's interest in her man wanes
slowly over time you know they say uh i
think it was esther perel in one of her
books
um desire in women
just tanks it just goes straight off the
cliff okay
very very quickly over time whereas with
guys it's a lot slower
why does that happen i think a lot of it
has to do with
where we live in you know the world
today and the way society is but i also
think it has a lot to do with the way
that guys manage relationships like
too many guys bend the knee two women
far
too often for very little value
whatsoever
you ever said stand up i think it was
chris rock or tucker you know
it just talks about the stamp just get a
stamp just stamp everything yes yes yes
honey yes yes yes yes yes yes
that's beta tization right you're saying
yes to everything you're yielding you're
bending the knee it's okay to say no
guys
it's absolutely totally fine and okay
nope we're not doing that
my mom should start chirping you some
women do anyway
nope not listening to that nonsense
either get your golf clubs and hit the
you know at the bars go to the gym
do whatever you like don't listen to
that crap
you